today on Star Talk special edition we
learn about a hopeful New Direction of
cancer treatments and how they work
could we one day rid Humanity of this
terrible multifaceted disease that
masquerades as our own cells as we try
to rid them from our
universe up next on Star
[Music]
Talk this is Star Talk Neil to Tyson
your personal astrophysicist serving as
your host today it's special edition and
I got with me my special edition co-host
Gary O'Reilly Gary hi Neil yeah former
Soccer Pro and sports commentator I also
got Chuck Nice Chuck always good to have
you man hey Neil So today we're taking
up the top very serious topic the
Emperor of all maladies cancer oh my
gosh Gary what did you put together for
today uh well finding a success
treatment for cancer has long been one
of medical science's biggest challenges
if not the biggest challenge so you know
with variable results and some rather
nasty side effects but there was one
particular cancer researcher at City of
Hope cancer research and Treatment
Center in Los Angeles decided as she
says follow the science and now we are
looking at the possibility of a
treatment that takes out the cancerous
tumor but leaves the healthy cells
around it
intact this yeah wow this is the kind of
science that really could change
people's lives and by the way our guest
once dreamed of being an astronaut so uh
yes if you would like to introduce Our
Guest I think we're GNA have an
interesting
show okay I'll introduce anyone who ever
dreamed of becoming an astronaut uh
Linda malus PhD Linda welcome to Star
talk thank you so much I'm such an honor
to be here you're associate chair and
professor in the department of molecular
and cellular biology at the City of Hope
cancer research and treatment center so
I'm just glad places like that exist in
this world and you have clinical
expertise in molecular Diagnostics and
experimental Therapeutics so it sounds
like you're all up in
this uh and so just welcome and so tell
us about cancer like what all I I have
basic understanding of cancer wait what
Chuck what do you I was gonna say that
sounds like the worst bedtime story
request
ever tell me read to me about tell me
about
cancer so so cancer is hard to treat as
I understand it because the the cells
look just like your cells so anything
would that would kill a cancer cell is
going to kill your cell and that's the
beginning and end of what I know about
cancer basically so what what can you
add to that and what can you tell us
about the new treatment well actually
you got a really good start with this in
that the that
cancer cancer I guess you know in in my
opinion is uh really kind of a way the
body turning on itself and cancer is
like uh you know being that I you
already know I'm a you know like a
science fiction geek so alien you know
if you think of the movie Aliens you
know you can think of cancer as you know
the most perfect Predator you know it it
really is it and it's why it's so hard
to treat because it looks like us it's
our own body it knows all our own tricks
you know how you know it's our processes
which it uses against us and then cancer
also has this
ability uh to constantly evolve it's
actually a very scary Predator it really
is and that's why it's so very very hard
to treat because it's constantly
changing itself it is such a weird
entity that's how I you know and I used
to when I was first studying you know I
would really look at it as like a you
know it's a cell you know but it's
almost like a living entity it is you
know if you think about it every day and
I want to congratulate you all you're
all cancer survivors every one of us
including myself every day since before
we were born we make at least eight
cancer cells and our immune systems take
them out so we're constantly making
eight cells per per day every day okay
per day okay day okay per day so we're
making at least eight cancer cells every
day and uh your immune system is
constantly surveilling and taking them
out we also have these other wonderful
processes in our cell we are constantly
making DNA damage just the act of eating
and and metabolizing food you're
actually making you know uh free
radicals which are attach you know
attacking your DNA and we have these
wonderful DNA repair
systems uh that go in and just clean it
all up and you know the cells divide and
and you know and we we're rather a
miracle that that we F that we we're
here and they are not giant tumors as it
is a cancer cell it's true it's true
true it's a miracle that we are
ourselves and not just tumors walking
around civilization tumors with eyes you
know so
um that's a Sci-Fi story just scared
myself so uh you know you you have these
cancer you so you have cells these you
know they become cancer
cells you know they're they're started
by DNA damage okay or mutation I mean
that's the heart of what cancer is is a
change to your genome change to your
your DNA but what happens with cancer
cells is they go on to make DNA they're
DNA damage to themselves they continue
it's called Uh uh constitutive
replication stress they are continually
damaging their themselves and you think
about that you go why would a
cell continue to make damage it doesn't
make sense it's like you know why are
you continually mutating your own genome
but that is a um the way I look at it
and others is actually it's an almost an
evolutionary mechanism for them like I
said you know every day we're making a
cancer cells we have this incredible
immune system that's constantly
surveilling and you know taking them
out so for a cancer cell to survive it
needs to constantly change it self so
that it can avoid the surveillance
system it sounds eerily like a virus the
way that that you explain it
diabolical yeah yeah and you know it's
interesting that you mention the viruses
because you know there is been thinking
for a long
time uh yeah that ways to even treat
some forms or cancer could you know
could we use things that you know we use
Target viruses we use them for cancer so
uh it's it's a it's a scary thing I
don't want to scare your audience
but you already
have you know so good things so you know
practice good health you know things
that that you know now I can't get
walking tumors with eyes out
of so what is what is what is this
treatment uh that has 1996 in the title
what what is this okay
so so it starts a long time ago I never
planned on being a cancer researcher
well I was going to be a space scientist
but it but I got really I fell in love
with the molecule of DNA so my very
early work had to do with if you look
inside the human cell there's nucleus
right and inside the new human you know
I always call the nucleus like the house
of DNA okay so in the house of
DNA you know the human cell Harbors
three feet of DNA inside the nucleus of
AR cell if you uncoiled it if you
uncoiled it uncoiled it all out and
stretched it out linear three feet of
DNA is shoved into something we can't
even see right wow you know if you took
all the DNA of every cell and tied it
end to end that the person will
die well probably but also all the DNA
out of one human and stretched it out
into space it goes beyond the sun wow
just from one human wow yeah that's how
much gentic information we Harbor that's
how much genetic information we Harbor
we are amazing machines and the person
dies in that case too yes well yeah
especially if you get close to the Sun
so so so when a you know every day every
you know so our gut you know we're like
a tube within a tube so your gut turns
over like every the two to three days
you know so there's a lot of cell
division that goes on in your gut and
every time uh you your gut cells have or
any cell in the in the human body has to
divide what you do is uh the Mother cell
has to make a whole new complement so
that's another three feet of DNA stuffed
inside of one nucleus and then it's
those two cells and the DNA are are
divided out so I got really interested
how how
does a human cell replicate its DNA in
such a confined space and inside of like
eight hours it makes that there isn't a
human machine that we have invented that
can actually do anything near this with
such incredible
Fidelity so um I got very interested so
I I um I got uh involved in studying DNA
replication complexes and then you know
as an IND independent investigator I
started reading about cancer and cancer
you know
is a disease of DNA damage that's really
what cancer is the crime scene of
replication yeah and and here here like
Agatha Christie here she goes so I go
and um and I say you know I'm like the
mother of replication complexes I can
make I literally can isolate from a
human cell a replication complex put it
into a test to offer a DNA and it would
make DNA just like you know inside the
cell so I said gee I wonder if this
complex is different in cancer cells
versus normal
cells and I won't go into the glory
details but the bottom line was yes it
was different in cancer cells cancer
cells corrupt the DNA replication
apparatus so that it allows a sprinkling
of DNA damage every time it makes a so
so actually you can almost think of the
daughter cells of a mother cancer cells
are different from its own mother that's
how how how it
changes so I so I found that and then we
started looking since I knew a lot of
the proteins that were inside of this
replication machine I started looking
through who was different and we found
one protein which I didn't think would
it be the protein I thought it was going
to be one of the cool DNA polymerases
you know but it wasn't it was a protein
called proliferating cell nuclear
antigen or
pcna now way back when when we first
found this altered form of
pcna um you know people would never have
looked at they always think it was like
this so it's it's called a sliding clamp
protein and I lik in it okay like if you
think of DNA as like a shower curtain
rod pcna is kind of like you shower a
curtain ring so so pcna is a sliding
clamp protein and en circles DNA and
what it does it it it tethers three
other molecules that have to work at
DNA and allows them to process and do
whatever it is that they have to do now
the cool thing about pcna
pcna okay interacts with at least 200
other proteins in the human cell it has
by protein protein
interactions so we found that
pcna was different in cancer cells
compared to normal cells and that that
difference in pcna correlated now with
this funky replication act right so I
got thinking I said
H suppose we make I mean you know
technically we found a a new molecular
Target this pcna that's different in
cancer
cells and it's not changed in the genome
it's not changed because of
RNA if I was to develop a drug to that
pcna to the form that's only in the
cancer cell and not in the normal cell
several things come from this one I
would I would Target and knock out only
the cancer cell because that drug would
only be affected inside the cancer cell
to kill the cancer cell but it would
also be super effective because it's not
just a talking one protein it's taking
out an entire
network of 200 protein functions inside
of the cancer cell while leaving that
same ner Network in place in a normal
cell that is the heart of what AOH 1996
is it is a molecule this was race to
find something different about the
cancer
celled people it totally is it's it's uh
it has so many novel features to it I'll
be very honest when we first found it
you know and you know everybody wers how
come it take so long to do you know
cancer why can't they do these things
fast well we had a you know this was
found is that what we sound like to you
is that what that's that's a
a lot of flying I'm on a lot of
airplanes and I'll sit next to people on
airplanes this has to happen to you too
but I'll sit on airplanes and I'll tell
people when I you know hey I'm a cancer
researcher I get a couple of different
things one is you know they already have
the cure for cancer they're just holding
it back you know oh god really gotta
love those people that what I get and
then the know they make so much money
off of treating cancer they can't cure
it and I'm just like you imagine how
much money they would make off of a
that's what I always say I said you know
the other one I always get so then the
other thing I get is um uh uh you know
why does it take so long because you
know finding a
Target moving it forward you know and
the this target was so different I
actually went to a very large Pharma
company uh way back when so this is a
when I first found it and I said hey I
found this great molecular Target can
you help me make a drug to it and they
uh they said it was
undruggable that there was no way why
was pcna undruggable then what was it
about that particular protein that at
it's changing there's Dogma okay there's
some Dogma in the field and Dogma was
you only uh make a drug against an
enzyme gotcha uh and so
it was quite crushing to me when I went
to this very large farmer company and I
danced for them you know I took all I
talked about replication complex I was
dancing for them and saying this is a
great Target and they very kind they
were listen to me and they said
undruggable you'll never be able to make
a drug to this it's it's involved in
protein protein interactions it's an
disordered protein region it's
impossible and I just you know when I
left that place you know oh my God how
could I have made such a how could I
have been so you know but by the time I
made the parking lot of that place I was
like I'll be damned I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to figure this
out and was great for wait wait don't
tell me you found the solution just to
spite somebody no no actually I I did it
no whatever the motivation is I guess no
no I made a promise to a family that I
was going to go and try to do something
okay about cancer wow so there's an
underlying heart issue here okay there's
a noble cause tell you a very noble
cause yes spite spite sells better
though well
no well yeah I guess spite would but
that's you know let me just tell you
something when when we make the movie
when we make the Linda malus movie about
you know the the the the the treatment
and the the the Cure of these certain
types of cancers um the spite angle is
what we're goingon to go with like the
family the family family would be
the spite is great fuel yeah but it
won't hold you for long term that's a
very good point AG that that really is a
really good point it really you can only
go so far because you you know you just
run out of fuel yeah that's good but
when it's a heart issue and it's a
promise that's something
else
I'm going to W the queen of different
thinking just for the moment was there
other different thinking that had to
follow your initial thought process that
obviously was different to everyone
else's that led you to ioh 1996 and its
efficacy so you think about how this
drug is working it is very different
okay it wasn't an enzyme targeting an
enzyme I I speak a lot an analogy one of
the ways that you shut down most the air
traffic in the United States is you send
a snow storm into oare and you shut down
all those roots okay so pcna is a
terminal okay a h it's an okay and
you're shutting down 200 flights out so
literally what I'm trying to do is build
a
snowstorm to take out a central Hub
that's going back to this sliding clamp
that you talk about these these proteins
all being connected and so what you're
doing is you're coming in and you're
saying I'm not going to treat this what
what I'm going to do is shut down the
system inside of the
system shut down the whole network shut
down the whole the whole thing so that
was really different as luck would have
it this place called City of Hope called
me out of the blue and asked me if I
would be an external advisor for them to
come in and review their research
program and so when I went there I had I
was blown away because they had put
together this incredible apparatus which
I hadn't seen inside of an academic
institution before where they had put
together all the people the resources
and the facilities for actually taking
an idea off a lab bench and moving it to
the
clinic and I was like this is where I
got to go so I moved to City of Hope and
they're wonderful I've got with all
these these great minds right but I
still had to do a lot of molecular
biology even to get them to be able to
work on what I needed to do and what I
had to do was figure out where on the
pcna molecule was the business part for
the
cancer and so what I did was I made it I
got the pcna gene out you know and we
made
mutations through
pcna and we made antibodies all kinds of
things and we were actually able to
Define
find a small domain of about 10 amino
acids which was the difference
between Cancer and
normal once I had that address on the
protein so you know every protein is so
beautiful each one has its own Crystal
stru you know if you look at the Crystal
structures they they're like their every
protein's like its own fingerprint so I
found on this big protein this little
bitty address
but it had that address had made a
formed a pocket inside of the
molecule and uh once I had that
pocket that's when I could start
screening for molecules and we screen
through 6.5 million
molecules that would sit and these are
humans or is it some form of AI doing
this it's a form of AI so it's a it's a
it's an you know you use these gigant so
this this is so cool I mean this is
called virtual screening so they have
you know these fantastic computers you
know with uh you know these databases of
of molecules just and they're like from
everything from trees and mushrooms and
you know from everything any kind of
structure of so the 6.5 million
molecules and you take your protein that
that 3D form of your protein and and I
got that little pocket sitting inside
that protein and you take that structure
and that little pocket and you stick it
in the computer and the computer goes
6.5 million times this
way right to see what puzzles together
those right right and it came up with
53 53 out of 6.5
million and we took them home and we
tested 53 compounds on normal versus
cancer cells and of the 53
compounds we found five that killed the
cancer cells and left the normal cells
alone wow and it was like oh my God but
that doesn't mean anything it's on a lab
bench and the work has been
duplicated yeah so then it becomes this
incredible process of you know having
that what they call it a hit so of those
five molecules we picked One MH um very
unique structure nothing looked like it
chemically and we moved it
slowly forward through the process so um
and it became AOH
1996 it's in clinical trial now it's in
a phase one trial is pH phase one with
humans so what phases with with with
other animals okay okay so is that one
of the fa yeah so the workup to get to
the FDA you have to do testing in
animals uh we did it in mice and
dogs um and the Beautiful part of it of
all those that testing was it did not
show toxicity we never found the maximum
tolerated dose the animals are very
happy on it I mean you know they're
they're they show no they eat uh they
show no neurological
problems um and in tumor models you know
animal tumor models we show that we
could inhibit uh tumor growth and with
all that data you go to the FDA and then
they granted permission now for the
phase one trial so we have patients that
have been enrolled in the phase one
trial uh and the phase one trial so
there's three levels of
trialing uh to move something to that
you know it can be used in the clinic
phase one is a toxicity trial you know
how what can we find the maximum
tolerated dose in humans and my I have a
strong suspicion we
won't um and then you go on to now
efficacy trials those are called phase
two trials where you know you're
testing you know do you see any effect
in on on a a person with tumor and then
phase three are these large trials you
know over different populations you
describe um cancer as a molecular
signature
disease um I can say that but I'm not
quite sure I'm anywhere near qualified
to explain what that means so would you
in in terms that I might understand what
that actually means because you don't
see it as singular you see it as
multiple diseases don't you yeah so when
I was learning you know I was training
cancer was really thought as like one
thing you know you had breast cancer you
had lung cancer you had prostate cancer
you had you know you whatever can it was
one type right and I used to work with a
a wonderful a breast cancer oncologist
out in Indiana and U he said it used it
would drive him crazy he said Linda I'd
have two women who come in with breast
cancer and my practice
and everything about them is the same
you know they they grew up in the same
street they have you know they have the
same number of
children everything I could measure
about them was the same he said I would
put them on protocol and one would
respond beautifully and one would die
and there was no way to tell the
difference that was our thinking for so
long that you know cancer was one thing
that has totally been radically Chang
now because cancer is probably as in
individual as your fingerprint well
cancer as it affects the individual yeah
yes so you think about your tumor now
your tumor has its molecular signature
you know the thing that's that you know
there's a lot of unique features that's
why you know this molecular signature
part of cancer is such a a a a h huge
breakthrough you know they call it
Precision medicine now right or moving
towards Precision medicine in that the
same thing as as designer medicine
you're getting there seriously you're
getting there um so you know if you and
and if you can think the tum like we the
other thing with that we had very myopic
Vision was that tumor was all by itself
but you also have to recognize that the
tumor is sitting inside of a host
so there's a the environment around a
tumor is going to
influence cancer activity just as much
as the tumor itself so if I'm not
serving dinner at home I don't like
being called a host there's something
about that well yeah I'm I'm cool with
it as long as there's as long as there's
not a parasite involved I'm all right
with it well you know that's my whole
point I'll tell you cancer is a parasite
it just hasn't figured out how not to
kill the host is Parasite I mean cancer
is Parasite so now a person comes in to
Clinic you have their genome red and you
can actually right figure out we're
moving to this we already do it in some
cancers but you look at their molecular
signature and you're starting to say oh
well you know this drug works better in
this place and you
know yeah even if the drug was found in
lung cancer but a woman could come into
the clinic with breast cancer with the
molecular signature of that of the
tumor that would really work well with a
lung drug I mean it's really amazing
we're really in a very very different
kind of time and an and a revolution in
time in
thinking so what what is the evidence
that one kind of cancer migrated from
one organ to another okay though that's
many women with breast cancer die of
brain canc I I don't want you to get
confused I don't want you to get
confused I want
so things going on one is metastasis you
know where you know like a woman has a
breast cancer and they will likely
metastasize to BR bone or brain I mean
it's kind of like it has a homing device
it will go there it likes that
environment you know the other thing
what I was but I want to stress is the
molecular signature is not a about
metastasis sometimes the things that are
helpful to a tumor to grow whether it's
breast or lung are the switching on or
off of particular
genes that so that is a molecular
signature that could help us potentially
either use current therapies or make new
therapies for that's a that's a you know
base molecular signature metastasis is a
whole another
animal so you said that we produce eight
cancer cells per day how does this
treatment differ in our body's uh
eradication of those eight cells and why
don't we just try to replicate what the
body so you have this antigen is is our
body making an antibody that actually
just uh kills these eight cells exactly
how is the body killing the eight cells
and why aren't we trying to replicate
that so it's good that you bring these
things up so that you know one of the
big arms or areas of research that is
going on is amuno theapy right it's like
harnessing the power of the immune
system and so you have you know the the
col cart T Cell Therapy there are um
immune checkpoint therapies huge this is
a a amazing question obviously in a
fully functional person our immune
system is keeping things in we're they
keeping cancer in Balance you know
you're in check they're keeping it in
check whatever reason you know we become
out of
balance you know or you're exposed to
some
environmental cause body doesn't
maintain that balance and more so there
are wonderful arms of research some of
it's going on at City of Hope very very
exciting where they are exploiting now
or trying to understand how to better
harness the immune system but you know
that's the thing is but I have to go
back
cancer constantly is figuring its way
around things that we throw at it you
know way back when when I was training
everybody said you know we're going to
find the cancer Gene the cancer
Gene it turns out there's lots of cancer
Gene I do not believe we will ever have
a single
therapy what we will have is and I
believe AOH 1996 is going to serve as
one of the agents in an arsenal we
already have an
Arsenal
but the object
is with using Precision
medicine that we are able
to turn cancer from a critical disease
into now a managed disease and we're
moving towards that I actually have a
friend who had breast cancer and she
never went into remission she lived for
years with can that's kind of like
prostate cancer most men most men die
with prostate cancer because it's so
it's such a slow growing cancer that
sometimes it's like well we keep an eye
on it you know there's no need to do
anything invasive uh because you'll be
dead before it kills
you yeah but it's a very painful cancer
for men it is I did not know
that no actually in some you know if it
you know if it progresses for them yeah
may I ask you AOH 1996 is administered
as a pill yes twice a day why why a why
a pill so why why a pill uh I wanted to
make it easier on the patient you know
as opposed to them having to be hooked
up to infusion but also based on the uh
the chemistry of the drug it has a
halflife of about five
hours and so in order to keep the drug
present all the time it needs to be
administered twice a day so it didn't
you know patient isn't going to come in
and be hooked up to an infusion you know
all the time so uh so it's a continu you
know the patient comes in uh they are
you know our phase one patients come in
they are you know checked
for you know certain how they're doing
and everything and then uh they're
giving their pills and they go home and
they they take it they take it twice a
day so Linda I heard you use the term
halflife is that in the way we would use
that term in physics uh where after a
certain amount of time there's half of
the thing that matters that's still
active going on yes absolutely
absolutely so the body you know it the
drug is metabolized you know eventually
a metabolize that's what eats it up so
it has a halflife metabolism yeah so
five hours there's half of the drug and
after another five hours half that was
right half of the half and so then you
got to pick it back up with another dose
right right so I get it okay yeah that's
like you know like anybody taking
antibiotics you know you some T take
have to take it three times a day or
twice a day it has to do with
maintaining a drug and I know but I
understand it precisely with that
terminology but I've never seen the term
halflife on a bottle of drugs they
should put put it on there and you know
why behind the label yeah they should
put it on there because it's so
important like when you said antibiotics
a lot of people screw up their
antibiotics because they're not taking
them when they're supposed to take them
or they don't finish them and it's so
important that you do that because of
that reason so maybe they they might
give them make it a little more urgent
it might make it more urgent if you said
AB you know that's actually the you know
for any drug you know if they say you
know take it every eight hours it's all
has to do with the drug halflife right
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good thing
to know I will henceforth think of it in
those terms yeah yeah because that
that's the half life of my aspirin right
yeah so I'll tell you the half I'll tell
you the half life of aspirin
children all
right you said AOH 1996 would most
likely be most effective as a
combination
therapy is that going to be beneficial
for cancer
resistance as opposed to like a single
pathway
therapy that's actually a wonderful
question Gary thank you so one of the
problems with cancer it's a pain in the
butt remember it's this evolutionary
thing going on with cancer so a woman
has ovarian cancer or a person has lung
cancer and they are treated with a
usually with a platin compound um right
off um and what what's a platinum comp
so they're they're pla they're they're
chemotherapeutics that uh
attack um uh you know it attacks DNA so
and it's also very toxic
because it can't tell the difference
between a normal and malignant cell so
it's targeting proliferating cells which
are cancer cells but you also have a lot
of proliferating cells that are healthy
that are healthy and that's why so many
chemotherapeutics are horrible because
they're targeting proliferating cells
and they can't differentiate it between
normal and malignant so for example as
we came to understand it um your hair
grows faster than most other things in
your body so that would be a byproduct
of the targeting of proliferating cells
is that correct yeah so your eyebrows
your toenails come off these are
horrible the side effects are horrible
you know you lo I mean it's you lose
your eyelashes you know your tongue you
know um your gut remember I told you
your gut is turning over turning over
two or two three days rapidly that's why
so many chemotherapeutics really are
have such bad
GI effects but going back to Gary's
question about combination therapies and
resistance well one with AOH 1996 you
know if it holds up for being very
non-toxic and effective
for treating cancer of course you can
now what you do is you and not just AOH
1996 this happens all the time the
thinking now is we're not going it makes
big Pharma unhappy because they always
want one big drug you know that's going
to treat everybody but now that the one
big drug or they call it mono therapy
we're moving away from monotherapy and
more going towards what they call
Cocktails okay is that you will put
together a variety of drugs you know
like treating testos cancer Chuck knows
a lot about cocktails Chuck knows I knew
that I knew that gag was coming
that so my joke is that AOH 1996 will be
the Olive in everyone's cocktail
so look at that so
so two things with AOH
1996 great hope down the line if it
proves to maintain its
non-toxicity um I hope that we've
already done studies in animals to show
that it complements a variety of
currently used drugs and in the presence
of our drug we can actually lower the
amount of some of these very toxic drugs
very significantly so the anal animal
can have you know they can still show
very
effective growth inhibition of the tumor
but they're not sick but your thing
about
resistance this has come up a lot for me
for this drug for AOH 1996 my lab has
worked really hard at trying to make
resistant cancer cells cancer cells love
to do this I mean like I was talking
about the patient you know
the lung cancer ovarian cancer patient
they respond beautifully but in a year
or two their cancer comes back right and
the're resistant now to like CIS platin
or carop platin AOH
1996 we can't make a resistance cell so
far and I'm thinking why if I like a lot
of therapies that are made against
kinases single enzymes remember they do
one fun and what the cancer cell can do
because it's such a little you know it
goes you know so you're treating you
know like with a kinas inhibitor you
know does a cancer cells will now change
the enzyme that that used to Target okay
that that drug would Target so now it's
resistant to the
drug um and cancer figures a lot of
different ways to become resistant to
drugs this is
amazing it's cancer is like a it's an
amazing it's unbelievable is is there
such a thing as cell intelligence I'm
trying to figure out because as I hear
you talk about this and I'm thinking
about viruses and these cells that that
tend to adapt and change and you know
reconfigure it's like what is going on
that this can happen is that just part
of our evolutionary process what what is
going on it was just surv take a stab at
that there's billions of
them exactly billions and billions yes
so so most will die they can't adapt to
the thing the few that do bada bing
there there you go that makes perfect
sense look at that Bing so Linda I just
spoke up out of turn did great no you
did
great there you
go you did
good so Chuck when it's a game of
numbers there's always somebody GNA slip
through the game yep look at that yeah
and and remember and it's constantly
changing its genome it's like locks you
know it's changing the locks so with the
with resistance now what I'm thinking
with our drug it's not a single enzyme
it's a
hub you'd have to change all those Gates
right you know all those proteins coming
in and going out so I have this I have
to write a paper on it I have a I'm
gonna for the first time ever and I
probably shouldn't but I have a hubba
hubba
hypothesis for treating kid it hubba
hubba so by attacking a hub like pcna
because it controls you know all these
this network if we could identify other
networks like pcna and start targeting
hubba hubba right you really would be
shutting down cancer cells of course you
have to find them very cancer
specific but uh as opposed to the the
very long time strategy of just s
targeting a single enzyme as opposed to
start targeting a single star you do a
whole galaxy you know you target
galaxies hubba hubba so Linda just so
take us out here in five years 10 years
what is the world look like things have
changed so much in the cancer therapy
field just in 10 years
you know from my
training in the last Millennium okay
last century you know where we thought
oh we're gonna find one cancer Gene One
Drug one Drug's gonna do it all you know
we were so naive to now the basic
understanding that everyone's tumor is
different but now with using molecular
signatures we're getting every tumor's
address we're figuring out where they
they live okay not just
locally I know where you
live I know where you live
t that's exactly what we're being able
to do Chuck is getting Philadelphia on
you right
there you don't have to come see me I'll
come see you
exactly exactly but you know the thing
is is with figuring out the underlying
molecular
signature of each tumor person's tumor
their personalized signature of that
tumor and now coupling it
with with this molecular signature you
respond to these subset of therapies so
when a lady comes in with breast cancer
you can say Mrs doe you have breast
cancer
6A and we know that 6A responds resp to
this cohort of
drugs and we'll effectively treat her
wow and she may be cured and if she
comes and if she comes out of re
remission we check that signature again
and we say wow we use this cohort of
drugs so I see I see great things going
you're going from carpet bombing to
Precision targeting it's amazing
drone strikes baby drone strikes drone
strikes it's it's like it's like walking
into a store buying a suit off the peg
or going to saval roow where the best
Tor in the world are spoke exactly spoke
for there you go that's fantastic they
spoke drugs all right Linda you said
you're from Queens New York is that
you're in now he's flushing yes yes
cancer never cancer never stood a chance
she's from Queens New
York what high school did you go to uh
so yeah so high school I went to St
Agnes in uh College Point St Agnes okay
yes and then for school I'm a graduate
of City University of New York Queens
College wow Cy all right well Linda
thank you for being on the show oh my
gosh we like intermittent beacons of
Hope which you have offered us all uh as
we proceed here and you know we this
special edition Star Talk is all about
many things just but the Human Condition
especially and you're at the center of
that for so many people out there so
thanks for sharing your expertise and
keep at it thank stop talking to us get
back get back to the lab absolutely
absolutely they're in there okay they're
in there working trust me all right Gary
good to have you Gary pleasure so glad
we had to chance to tell this story yes
all right Chuck good to have you there
pleasure Neil degrass Tyson for another
edition of Star Talk special edition as
always as Linda taught us once again
keep looking
[Music]
up